de los últimos seis gobiernos del
salvador que han tenido que enfrentar a
las pandillas oa las maras como secuela
de la guerra civil que terminó en 1992
ninguno como el de najib que le había
logrado tal captura de pandilleros según
registros del propio gobierno se cuentan
más de 70 mil pandilleros en todo el
territorio salvadoreño y en 30 años de
lucha contra estas estructuras
criminales el saldo de capturados era de
apenas 16.000 de manera que con el
anuncio del presidente de eeuu que le
terminada la jornada de este miércoles
de haber capturado más de 20.000
pandilleros se puede registrar que ya es
más de la mitad del total de los
pandilleros los que se encuentran en
prisión sin embargo diferentes
organizaciones internacionales como
amnistía internacional human rights
watch y la ong cristos al quien presentó
reciente un informe se están llevando a
cabo graves violaciones de los derechos
humanos según la ong cristos al se han
compilado más de 147 detenciones de
personas que no estarían relacionadas
con los pandilleros además de la muerte
de cinco personas bajo a policial pero
el gobierno del presidente buque le
defiende que este estado decepción es
necesario y lo hace con este tipo de
cifras récord como la de 20.000
pandilleros capturados y la de seis días
consecutivos con cero homicidios